this is thanks for the crabapples
Giuseppe is I suggest that be okay I'm
looking up spelling of it right now and
I still can't say it oh and I just now
get this title card the more I look at
it too having seen the episode Finn and
Jake looking up the fireworks now Oh
so it's fine we're done the last episode
how like it was mostly new characters
and this one like they're all repeat
characters like every single one of them
um but skipper Giuseppe yeah except for
just at the event we know of maybe you
know somewhere but so all these wizards
and magical people gets again they're
going on a road trip and they just sort
of pick up all these wizards and just
Giuseppe who they don't know who he is
and he has it's anything but they're
like you know just come aboard Oh Oh
sounds like a road trip it is Africa
Daniel who is not dead because wasn't
there a theory before I like he might be
dead I thought he might be dead because
that's how they were trying to bring
that other guy to life yeah so like
maybe somehow used him but he's alive I
must like that's his body taken over did
you write the show yes oh wow it's good
episode so so they're going on this trip
and they finna Jake think they're gonna
get invited but they're not is that it's
the what were they called again the
water nymphs the water dance they come
back which most of simple so just
watching their hair it's like it's so
hypnotic like wow just where does it
land how does it keep going back it's
like over your family um bye kiss water
yes interesting about the hair now okay
so they go on this trip we're gonna go
to buttcheek mountain no no butt Rock no
no yes I know because there's chicken
there's our like they need in the crack
of the cheek was that in the cheeks at
the peak at the peak of the peak of the
cheek that was it yeah that was it
okay it's fire the way they put it it's
the way you're trying to
together but cheap but rock top of the
peak stop are you just happy that the
letters flying around my head are
forming words so give you some credit
they're gonna go and they're gonna try
and create this new spell and all of the
hijinks they come across and one of the
people I get left behind the only one
actually is again Giuseppe who gets left
at the crabapple tree and they get stuck
in the middle of this pond the some of
the Ice King I guess makes a spell that
knocks the mouth was there I could gas
through something I almost like he did
intentionally but I guess not
I guess he gets knocked out too and it
was a wonderful smooth great timing on
that joke and so they're all about to
drown they try every type of hilarious
spell the girls go outside and like we
can help and you think they're gonna do
something with water what there is so
these deadly try to lift it which
obviously does nothing it's like let's
go away I love ice king then they tried
to bring the bus alive but the bus can
swim then they try to one person tries
taking some pills his head gets replaced
with tree trunks and then Ice King tries
it his head gets replaced with the
wizard right next to him which is
brilliant that's not a great
joke I was I was laughing hard at that
joke and finally uh just that because
there he lifts them up cat-like Yoda as
you brought up puts it down and it just
sort of disappears into dust particles
that form his face a giant waking face
of him and now those wizards have
something really special that they can
bond over because they were kind of the
loser I'm like those snooty little
secret groups yes
except less Turkey so yeah again it was
May because it came on the heels of one
where's so much of it was new characters
there's no there was something I really
like seeing these characters come back
give us of my you know
oh I forgot about you know that
character and that person and stuff ah
and even just callbacks to like tree
trunks being there and Wow flying and
yeah and I sort of I I really like the
part where it it was like the world's
shortest poem whatever but the same time
it's like they're all crying over and
I'm kind of like at that point where
they're all crying I really thought they
were gonna like turn back and get him
but no they're just like okay next one
yeah I'm flying era but and like they
just never look back so yeah I I really
liked it I liked umm again interesting
detail on the crabapple tree - they had
sort of their shading there again and I
know they had shading other times on the
show - I'm just like I don't know
noticing it more I guess when they use
it I get maybe being away from the
person along that's true but ya know I
like seeing these whizzers together I
like that they are kind of the looser
wizard so they can't figure out even
just how to get out of a bus yeah and
the crew the really creative ways they
come up with but none of them work you
know and then they just create really
funny scenarios so I thought it was
really really funny and it had a kind of
a nice sweet ending there - its I felt
that bond very quickly of this big group
of people like they really because
they've tried different combinations and
stuff before and most the time they've
worked but this one I really felt like a
bond between yeah all these people even
if they're just leaving a behind door
and screaming and stuff but still it oh
I still felt was there so I really liked
it I just loved the bus oh we're out of
gas and then Ulsan here's a sudden the
thud and little dudes like and the
wheels fell off and then out comes some
hunter who's hiding behind cows and his
field and he's just but he's like yeah I
got here I can't see you so well but I
love that that was dana snyder again
that was fun and I loved my favorite
still is
oh no it's a bunch of wizards yeah
they're probably gonna want to go on an
adventure you go I don't want to do that
then you see everything and you'll go up
to the water nymphs and all that stuff
and then Olson finish it come running
out with backpacks yeah like that's
their contribution to the whole big dad
having the title card let's just snap
but like they're tight like Jake's
talking crap about going with them but
he obviously still wants to hear and
they're like yeah we don't be at those
losers what I like too is this sounds
like a road trip you would I mean even
though they kind of loser wizards and
stuff what they want to do you
legitimately would kind of want to do to
account sounds like something you would
go I mean I approach it if magic existed
and this stuff were possible and he does
not do it anyway I know I agree with you
I would so want to go on this road trip
I it's kind of funny because I it was
one of those laugh out loud moments and
I felt immediately like I was right
smack in the middle of their little trip
I thought that was really really cool
and it is something I would want to go
to even though I wouldn't but I but I
did because everybody was fun and and
and part of it is nostalgic because you
already kind of know them but seeing
their interactions with each other was
actually really kind of cool what the
poetic what I mean we okay Jason's gonna
have his poetic teepee going on here
don't know it's gonna give it to you you
said you wanted to go on this adventure
so continued as soon as you make the
house move I'll write the great poetry
on toilet paper house moved once it was
fun I just it's you know it was just a
really fun kind of feel-good type of
situation kind of like those camping
trips or I don't know it just felt very
fun very light-hearted
it was all around a good time I don't
exactly know how else to explain it and
also yes those those water nymphs hair
really could stare at it thought I
really could just stop and stare all the
time with them that was so cool
probably something wrong I don't wanna
be right
no there's gotta be other people that
right wasn't it cool it's neat but I
really hypnotized I guess right I could
just every time they were on screen that
my eyes just went directly like we are
at least I'm sober I don't know about
them
you sound sober wait a minute you're the
one that got the TP gave it to me is
just like yeah yeah - OH
actually I think you're ignoring me oh I
apologize I heard it's just like my two
dads I want to be the cool one you'd be
the gay one because he was gay right I
assumed they both work that's good big
sense did you ever see my two days no
but again I'm assuming they both work no
actually they were both straight hole
writer and someone else yeah oh the cool
dad in the uppity dad yeah I assumed
they were both gay like you know how all
the three guys on the house were gay
there obviously oh that was yes
definitely yeah there's no denying that
yeah Jack Tripper was not no he totally
was you know why no him and Larry well
without a doubt they were so in the
closet burly mr. Furley was mistaken
okay um yeah I liked the episode I
thought the episode was fun
it reminded me a lot of like the 80s
types of movies like The Goonies and
stuff like that where they're going like
the misfits are going on some
misadventure or what not yet
but this one was a little bit otter and
that makes me actually question
abra-cadoodle because the crown drives
Ice King insane well over a long amount
of time what you can remember in the
episode Finn the human
when Finn puts it on and only took a
little a couple seconds maybe a minute
or so and he started to already lose his
mind
yeah what Daniel didn't say it maybe has
something to do what people can do magic
knows that's what I'm curious about is
it that either abracadaniel is that
innocent or is it that he's got that
much magic power in him that he can
actually fend off the madness I'm a
customer for each person - that's true
maybe it's you know about that Jason
don't give me that look that's a camera
that's not the lucky crazy so I liked it
I thought it was a fun episode very cute
well I know some of you brought those
interesting you say very much count like
an 80s kids journey or something like
that like Goonies or something I thought
start off like a seventies movie like
the road trip movies and then sort of
work this way into like yeah the
eighties like we're in a predicament now
how are we bunch of goofy guys gonna get
out of this cuz a lot of people did that
in the seventies den day it was all
about road trips and catching
hitchhikers and so on so forth and yeah
that was like it you're saying that
seventies wasn't it like people could
just hitchhike a like wasn't a big deal
but this is before they found out about
you know psychos and stuff I really
wasn't alive in the 70s well I was like
for many years well I was because I'm
older than all of you you're such a liar
liar well done I know III heard but I
watched a lot of the hater
stories my mother and grandma this is no
I watched a lot of Wonder Years and that
was something they had was there was a
lot of hitchhiking that happened then
and so I here so anything else in the
episode I like little dude and I like
dana snyder they love Master Shake he's
pretty great yeah no I'm done what you
give us that's what you're supposed to
wipe with it it